tout au sud de la russie
la route pour la frontière avec le
dombass
soudain sur notre droite des chars
d'assaut juste au bord de la route
au moins une quinzaine de blindés de
l'armée russe a été positionné ici
une petite partie des cent mille soldats
déployés par la russie dans l'ouest du
pays
dans le village de sang avec juste à
côté
tout le monde a remarqué le retour des
militaires mais ici on a pris l'habitude
de vivre avec la guerre à sa porte
non il ya qu à la télé que c'est la
crise
nous avons chez nous dans notre pays ils
ne nous font rien
depuis 2014 sept régions russes est aux
premières loges du conflit dans le
donbass des habitants de donetsk eux
sont même venus se réfugier dans ce
village
des slaves jackpot en mange ici pour eux
c'est plus facile de vivre vous n'êtes
pas sous les tirs comme la barre
il n'y a pas la peur qu'on vous prenne
quelque chose d'être tué au bio c'est
plus calme ici
alors ici le président russe est vu
comme un protecteur et la présence de
l'armée rassure qu'est ce que vous
croyez nos frontières ne doivent pas
être protégées on doit nous abandonner
bravo poutine il se défend je suis fier
de lui voilà il est comme ça notre
président
plusieurs délits dont nous ont dit
craindre que le danger ne viennent de
l'ukraine le discours officiel russe
sait que le cren prépare des
provocations contre les séparatistes
dans le donbass